overhearing you in the hallway I learned
that you are a gamer oh yeah oh yeah so
like all I heard were you talking about
with Street Fighter you know what are
you talking Street Fighter 2
Championship Edition
or we know we're talking like the og
Street Fighter before they added you
know Cammy and I think Championship
Edition is still or maybe that does have
Cammy in it yeah um but that's okay cuz
those are some good characters too but
yeah right now I have a boss logic the
artists from Australia who does a lot of
hard for a lot of the films is he and I
have a challenge that we're gonna
complete tonight after I wrap up work
here do you have a character on Street
Fighter I'm alright Ryu guy for the most
part in guile I was gonna say I'm a big
fan of Ken and I also do like Zangief
yeah he's tough well if you know how to
play him Blanco my brother was blocking
that's just cheap you've moved to Pig
Blanca well what's the thing I love
about the game and this is not where I
was going with this interview is that I
love that each player has pros and cons
in terms of like if you are a master of
like Chumlee you you can win yes you
know what I mean totally totally and the
ins true but also if you can't you know
if you're playing different styles of
play and you're randomizing what we like
to do is just me and my buddies call
dividers choosers so one guy picks the
two combatants and the other guy picks
which one he wants to be so so yes you
can ever you can't ever just lock in on
one character you have to be versatile
sure is there an arcade in LA you want
to plug or no you know I mean we just
did that D&B down in Hollywood has got
all the games and then of course there's
a cool bar what's it called 1982 sure
downtown Lilly I know that's year I was
born so I really like that place jumping
into why I get to talk to you today one
of the things that I loved about this
film one of the many things is that Tim
did a phenomenal job with the action
set-pieces in terms of design so you
could easily follow what was going on
exactly
you know um talk a little about crafting
these things with Tim and maybe what
surprised you about making a film on
this level well we I worked very closely
I always worked very closely with my
stunt guys with my stunt community
there's there
that I love them I feel most at home
talking with them I feel like we share a
lot of similar qualities and we come
together we build these fights and I'm
thankful to - to Phil and Freddie B and
Jimmy Choo and Jason Morgan everybody my
whole team for building these fights
showing us these great pre pre pre
visualized builds of the fights and then
and then we take the Tim and then Tim
just takes a hatchet to it and he's like
nope we don't need that we don't need
that we don't need this everything has
to have a point there's no reason for
him to be doing that move or that move
there's everyone is a kill strike every
parry is is absolutely necessary every
move is a breath and that's what that's
what I love about Tim let's see there's
no fighting for fighting sake just for
have just some chaos on the screen
everything is very dialed in very
specific and uh and so that was really
appreciated that I really appreciated
his attention to detail and with a film
like this with so much happening if it
could just become very unwieldy and just
kind of fly off instead of just chaos
so that was an element of it he wanted
to make sure that the film of this of
this size you know they don't get made
very often and I'm really lucky and
fortunate to be part of something to
have this experience learn what it is to
put your body through that test for
seven and a half months and see how you
come out the other end yeah I already
got to go but that's something I think a
lot of people don't realize making a
film like this is so much time and so
much energy yeah you know yeah and yeah
I gotta take care of yourself gotta take
a drink a glass of water